Do the books or letters have any hints at what weapon did.
We're on use at the final battle of the war of the last Alliance.
One weapon that sound is described as using, and it's his hands.
He is said to have killed Gilgo ad with his burning hand.
So sour on his hands were like fire.
So the only actual weapon that siren is described in the book as using is his
own hands. And I ha I think you have to admit that's, that's pretty metal.
This is Corey Olson, the talking professor, and this is talking support.
Okay. Gail Simone asks,
does anyone know if the syllabics near reversal of the names fatten and Dennis
Thor was intentional?
Yeah. So first of all, Gail, I would say,
I certainly agree with you about the way that those two characters parallel each
other. That seems a really important thing.
And Dennis Thor who's despair leads him to madness. Ultimately,
in the end,
I would say that the relationship between their names is semi accidental Tolkien
as always derived the names of his characters from the languages
that he was dealing with. Dennis Thor comes from his own,
made up languages, Fayette, and does not. They,
it didn't comes from Anglo-Saxon. Uh, the language of the row here, um,
is essentially Anglo-Saxon and Faden in Anglo-Saxon basically
means King as the, uh, talking scholar, Mike drought.
Who's also an Anglo-Saxon scholar has pointed out.
If you go through the names of all of the Kings in the history of Rowan,
almost all of them have names. That mean King is like King son of King,
son of King, son of King,
almost the entire genealogy of the Kings of Roohan all basically mean King and
Denis. Thor is from the Elvis languages. However, uh, you know,
Gail having said that,
is it a coincidence that their names do kind of resonate in that way?
No, I don't think it is a talking had a really good ear. Uh,
he was very sensitive to the sound of words,
the way in which their two names involve a lot of the same sound properties kind
of shuffled around in different ways is I think something that probably would
have appealed to him as he was certainly aware of the way that their two
characters were developing. Mark.
That is a person named Mars. Presumably not the planet.
As I rewatched the Lord of the rings movie,
I still wonder what is sovereign human or bad hell for some other creature?
Great question. So saffron is a must.
Yeah. An angelic being, he is not a mortal creature,
either elf or human. There were in talking's world.
A lot of these sort of,
kind of semi divine creatures kind of like angels Celeron was one of these.
Some of them, of course, many of them were good. That's ultimately,
that's what Gandalf is also one of these same creatures.
He is a spiritual being taking physical form.
That's why when he dies, because he's actually slain,
his body is killed in the battle and his spirit fleas, but his spirit is great.
We weakened this, but it's not gone.
So he is eventually able by the time of the Lord of the rings, he can manifest,
uh, in a physical body again.
All right. Morgan, number five asks when Gandalf went from gray to white,
was it just a one-off or was it a company-wide promotion did routing as the
Brown become Radigan.
The gray, it would have been tough for Ella and.
Polando going from blue to Brown.
Okay, good. Excellent question. It is a very natural thing.
When we read about the color of the wizards to imagine that the wizards color is
a sign of rank and that there is a hierarchy,
a strict hierarchy among the colors.
Here's how I understand the colors of the wizards.
The colors of the wizards are a sign of their,
not of their ranks, but of their roles of their particular jobs.
Solomon had a job. He was the white and as the white wizard,
he had a job and his job was to be the enemy of Celeron and
to lead the forces of good against sour on Solomon gets canned
from his job and Gandalf takes over his job.
This is why when Gandalf returns, he's the white,
not just because he's more powerful. He is more powerful,
but because he has a new role and he is now the white wizard.
And when he comes back, you'll notice he acts like it.
He is in the forefront leading the good guys overtly
as the enemy of sour on that is Solomon as he should have been.
That is what the white wizards job description is.
Now this leads to a very sensible question.
What is the job description of the grey wizard? What was Gandalf's job before?
It seems that his job as the gray is to go around and encourage and support
people just as a rat aghast, the Brown, his remit is clearly birds and beasts,
right? He is the friend of birds and beasts.
Gandalf's remit is not birds and bees, but people.
And the way that we see him going to the kind of relationships that we see him
establishing in, Gunder in love, Lorian in the Shire,
suggests that going around and encouraging and supporting these different
populations of people.
That seems to be as far as we can tell what the job description of the grey
wizard is. So, no, I do not think that, uh,
all of the wizards get a company-wide promotion.
The shift from gray to white is a change in job description for Gandalf,
not a rank.
Promotion. So Ryan asks.
Do they have campuses in middle earth?
Does Arctic get magnetic poles after the [inaudible]
? Yes, it has poles. Do they have campuses? I don't think so. We have no references to anybody
use encompasses and finding magnetic North does magnetic North exist
. Yes, it certainly does the reference to does to
get magnetic poles after the Akala Beth, that Ryan asks, of course, the
[inaudible]
is the story of the downfall of Newman or the old version of talking's
mythology.
The elder days in talking's world are a flat earth mythology.
They take place on a flat earth when the Island of Newman arm is
sunk beneath the sea. At the end of the second age, the world is made round.
So it's not just that the Island drops,
but the world is made round at that point.
So does RD get magnetic poles at the point when it's made round? Yes.
It certainly has them. Does anyone navigate by them?
That is not at all clear. So again, there's no explicit references to campuses,
but a compass would certainly work in middle earth. That seems fairly clear.
A question from Zachariah S pumpkin's.
If the black speech of mortar is so ugly to listen to how come it looks so
pretty when inscribed upon the one ring it's written in Tang war,
but did the black speech have no written components,
was sour on flexing his calligraphy or was it.
Elvis has only choice? Um, really interesting question that script of course,
was designed by. It was invented by talking. He invented several,
not only languages, but also scripts sour on devised the black speech,
because he had an ORIC problem. He had communication issues in his armies,
the Orks couldn't communicate with each other. So he invents the black speech.
In some ways,
it actually was kind of a failure as a linguistic experiment by siren.
This script that fits his language does not fit the work that he wants to
do. So the fact that he asked to borrow from the elves,
borrow their script in order to make his inscription on the ring is a little bit
of an indictment against Saudi Iran and kind of shows in the end.
He can't really create new, wonderful things himself.
He's not capable of creating beauty.
He is in the business of tearing beauty down.
All right. John Carney asks the classic and excellent question.
What happened to the ENT wives?
The answer we don't know.
Tolkien was asked this many times.
He answered this question a couple of times in his letter and his answer.
There was, I don't know though.
He does say on one or two occasions that he suspects that they're dead.
The N wives lived in the lands down near
the end when North of the [inaudible] place, that's called the Brown lands.
They're quite close to Mordor. I'm not exactly on the doorstep, but you know,
they're like a suburb of Mordor where they all slain by sour on where they
scattered and do they still exist somewhere? Talking said,
he didn't know for sure. It's a mystery.
There are several things that he deliberately left mysteries that he said he
himself didn't know the answer to.
So nobody can give a definitive answer to that question.
All right. Another question from Signore P for non hobbits,
can you name one other town or village in the Shire that isn't,
Hobbiton sure there are lots of towns.
And the Shire nickel Delvin is the name of the capital of the Shire,
essentially. It's the center of the Shire. Uh, the two other.
Most important places in the Shire are.
Buckland, which is the home of the Brandy bucks and tuck borough,
which is the home of the Tooke family.
And there are a number of other towns that they pass through Bywater, of course,
which is right next to Hobbiton. There's what all in stock, uh,
and several other towns along the way that we hear about during the journey of
the hobbits, they're in the fellowship of the ring.
Jeff airmen asks,
I always find it funny that the plural of elf is elves,
but the plural for Dorf is dwarfs, not dwarves talking popularize.
This, I read that it has to do with the origin of the word dwell org,
old English or dwarf.
Exactly.
So this is something that talking as a philologist that is somebody who
studied language quietly rebelled against it is true that the traditional
plural of dwarf the technically correct plural is dwarfs
and talking hated that because linguistically it is not sound.
It just does not work. It doesn't make sense. Uh,
so he innovated his pluralization dwarves,
which he insisted on in the Hobbit is his kind of rebellion
against what really is not a very sensible pluralization at all.
And actually it's funny,
he had a bunch of arguments with the proofreading staff,
especially at Houghton Mifflin, the American publisher who kept correcting it,
like the, the, the copy editors kept going back and changing it to dwarfs.
And they'd send him the proofs and he'd be like, guys, no, like, trust me.
Who's the professor here.
Comes in from Kevin Hearn who asks,
I never understood the urgency of hopping on the last boat to Valin,
or why was it the last boat?
This is almost certainly a Laura thing I missed in the books. Why couldn't,
Arwin just build a raft and head West later. And Hey, Frodo got on a boat.
Couldn't our windows made that one.
So the boats in question are sailing from the havens of the elves
and they are headed into the West Capitol w and when the world was
made round, the,
the far West was removed from the world.
You can't get there anymore,
but one straight path still remains.
That is straight in the sense of being tangential to this fear of the earth so
that the straight road leaves earth and goes to Valen,
or which has been taken apart into a separate place.
It's no longer part of the purely physical world anymore,
but it is still part of art. Uh, and there is still a connection.
There is still this kind of umbilical cord between the world and Valentina,
and that, that path,
that straight road has been left explicitly in order that the
elves who still remain in middle earth can still escape and go to the blessed
realm, go to Elvin home.
They're given by the Valor of the privilege of sailing on the straight road.
That's where Frodo and Bilbo with Gandalf and Elrond and the others who depart
in the ship there from the Harbor at the end of the Lord of the rings,
that's where they're headed as for Arwin herself.
She does not get on a boat because she has chosen
mortality. The choice of Arwin is a really big deal.
Humans and elves have completely different fates.
What happens to elves at the end of the world, the world,
going to come to an end. And when it comes to an end, the elves had done,
did they all die or all elf souls annihilated at the end of ARDA,
they don't know. So the big deal,
when Arwin chooses to marry, Aragorn, it's an enormous deal.
She is leaving.
She has permitted the choice to leave the fate of elves.
She's she ceases to be an elf anymore. She becomes mortal.
She embraces mortality and a human fate.
And so therefore she is not going to be going into the West. And when she dies,
when her body dies, her spirit is not going to go into the West.
That's why such a big deal is made of the farewell between Elrond
and Arwin because he is going to go to [inaudible] and he's going to remain
there. His spirit will remain there even after his body dies, if his body dies,
uh, and Arwin is going to go wherever humans go.
Stanton asks, is there a Jarrod talking book about the goblin and dwarf?
Great war. Excellent question to which the unfortunate answer is no.
There is no such book, the longest description,
the most information we get about the war between the dwarves and the goblins or
orcs, uh, is in the last section of appendix a in the return of the King, uh,
is on the people of Durham.
And that's where we get the description of the battle of as a Newell bizarre,
uh, to use the dwarfish name for it. It's only about a one paragraph summary of,
of the war, uh, itself building up to that battle. That was the final battle.
In fact,
that section of appendix a has not only the most that we get about that war
between the goblins and dwarves,
but it's also the most information we get about dwarves.
Full-stop we learn more in that section of appendix a then really we learn
anywhere else, including.
A question from Jacob Williams. Isn't the marring of ARDA,
the doing of Melcor and the raising of the hands of.
The verses of the song,
folding his grief to the reconciliation is so Milkar is the big,
bad of middle earth. And I mean, big, bad of middle earth.
He is essentially the Satan figure of, you know,
the entirety of Tolkien's world.
He is the second most powerful creature in existence. Second,
only to God himself. Um, at least in the beginning, he was the second,
most powerful. He rebelled against God. I get, uh,
paralleling the story of Satan in Christian tradition.
One of the chief differences between Tolkien's mythology and Christian
Judeo-Christian mythology is that toking describes Melcor
as having marred artists. So ARITA again is the whole world.
It's the solar system and the entirety of the world has been
tainted essentially by milkers malice.
And that's why everything is tending towards a decay and tragedy.
That's basically why,
why do bad things happen to good people in middle earth milk or that's
arrow? The one, uh, Eluvia tar who has God,
he does respond to that, his message to milk,
or is there is nothing that you can do that is ultimately going to mess
up my plan for the world.
And you will find that everything that you have done to try to mess up middle
earth is only going to end up contributing to the ultimate beauty
and glory of my creation. Um,
so tokens theology there is that God is still in charge.
Okay. Antonio asks,
did Sarah just turn Newman or into a Melcor cult making human sacrifice in the
name of the giver of freedom? Yes, yes. Antonio,
that is exactly what sour on did. Siren was extremely cunning.
He could not compete with the Newman Koreans on a military basis.
So siren gives in, so they bring him back as a prisoner to Newman army.
And he does that because he really wants to go to Newman manure and he works on
corrupting it from within. So yes,
he turns Newman art into a devil worshiping cult and ultimately convinces them
to attack the last enemy that they have not defeated the ones who have been
doing them wrong all these years,
namely the elves and the Valor over in the West. It is really fun. Uh,
to talk about your questions,
I really appreciate all the questions that you guys asked here today.
It's so interesting, of course,
that we're able to still talk about talking to have these kinds of debates and
discussions 80 years later. Well, I'm Cory Olson, the talking professor,
and this has been talking support.